Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Die Ligatur ist wieder zurück. Wir blicken auf den europäischen Männerfußball. Da ist so einiges passiert. Wir werden es aufarbeiten in eurem Lieblingsformat hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 257. Ich begrüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und schön, dass auch sie alle wieder mit dabei sind. Ich begrüße jetzt mal Nils Kern, hallo Nils. Hola, buenos días.
Schön, mal wieder dabei zu sein.
Hi, da bist du laut auf einmal. Das war im Vorgespräch aber nicht so, aber schön, dass du hier bist. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Euphorie, die hattest du vorhin. Na ja, gut, da werden wir gleich darüber sprechen. Dann begrüße ich Jogi Hebel. Hallo Jogi. Und David Frogier de Ponlevoy ist wieder dabei. Hallo. Und neben mir sitzt Christian Bernhard. Hallo Christian. Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Wir legen gleich los. Ich möchte aber vorher noch zwei Ankündigungen machen. Zum einen, der Rasenfunk finanziert sich ausschließlich über die Crowd, also über euch Höhrende da draußen. Bitte tut das auch, rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Leute da draußen, die nur die Ligatur hören, würde ich natürlich streng verurteilen. Aber andererseits darf jeder leben, wie er leben mag. Aber was ich auch sagen wollte, es empfiehlt doch die Ligatur gerne weiter. Also inzwischen haben wir jetzt ja eine Regelmäßigkeit gefunden, die wir auch versuchen beizuhalten. Alle zwei Wochen gibt es die Ligatur und ich habe das Gefühl, dass noch gar nicht so viele mitbekommen haben, dass es das jetzt im Rasenfunk auch wirklich regelmäßig und verlässlich gibt. Also empfehlt doch mal bitte den Rasenfunk weiter an diejenigen Freunde und Freundinnen von euch, die das interessieren könnte. Und dann habe ich noch eine Nachricht an alle Leute, die aus dem Großraum Ulm kommen. Ich beziehe da Stuttgart mit ein, denn da gibt es bisher noch keine Lesung. Ich werde am 20. April, das ist genau nächste Woche, werde ich in Ulm lesen, im Roxy. Da stand schon dritte Wahl auf der Bühne. Finde ich lustig, dass ich mir eine Bühne mit ihnen teile. Natürlich aus meinem Buch aus Liebe zum Spiel. Deshalb wird es den Zweitliga-Kurzpass nächste Woche auch schon am Dienstag geben. Denn am Donnerstag bin ich ja dann – na, wo bin ich da? in Ulm. So ist es richtig. Das reicht mit der Vorrede. Jetzt beginnen wir mit der Sendung. Und wir haben den Vorteil, dass wir einen Champions-League-Abend hinter uns haben. Und nachdem der Nils schon so super, super selbstbewusst hier angekündigt hat, dass Real nach seinem 2 zu 0 gegen Chelsea da im Auftaktspiel weiter ist, geht an dich die erste Frage. Nils, wie fandest du die bisherigen Partien, die wir so sehen durften im Viertelfinale?
Und weil es eben so ein großer Aufreger war, war es sicherlich auch gut, das hier nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher zu besprechen, als es auch in Medien gelandet ist. Ich habe unter anderem eine Schlagzeite gelesen. Wir haben noch ein Thema aus der Serie A. Wir wollen uns mit der Fiorentina beschäftigen, Christian. Und könnte es damit zusammenhängen, dass wir uns deswegen mit ihnen auseinandersetzen, weil sie unter anderem neunmal in Folge in Pflichtspielen gewonnen haben. Und insgesamt, wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht erzählt habe, aus den letzten 13 Spielen Pflichtspielen ungeschlagen sind und daraus 11 Siege und zwei Unentschieden geholt haben. Du bist und bleibst einfach ein Fuchs. Ja, die nächste heiße Mannschaft. Und weil du vorhin ja auch gemeint hast, wir schauen jetzt auf Platz 8 oder 9, ist ja auch schön, über die Großen haben wir ja immer wieder gesprochen. Aber es gibt eben auch ein paar Mannschaften, die auch ihre Sache in Italien sehr, sehr gut machen. Und dazu gehörten in Bologna selbstverständlich auch die Fiorentina. Du hast sie schon angesprochen, haben am Wochenende knapp ihren zehnten Sieg in Folge verpasst. 1-1 gegen Spezia, sind aber weiter ungeschlagen. Rollen das Feld so ein bisschen von hinten auf, denn eben vor dieser Siegeserie lief es ergebnistechnisch überhaupt nicht in der Liga, waren wirklich relativ weit zurück. Aber das Spannende war, dass das damals wirklich auch nur die Ergebnisse waren. Denn wenn man sich die Fiorentinaspiele angeschaut hat und nicht nur die Spiele, sondern auch die Statistiken dazu, die Fiorentina war schon zu der Zeit, als es nicht lief, ergebnismäßig, in ganz vielen Offensivstatistiken die Nummer 2 der Liga nur von Napoli geschlagen. Also was Torschüsse betrifft, was herausgespielte Chancen, was Ball besitzt, in all den Kategorien war auch da schon nur Napoli stärker. Also es zeigt, das 4-3-3 von Italiano ist Vincenzo Italiano, der Trainer, auf dem kommen wir auch noch, hat da eigentlich schon gegriffen, nur was gefehlt hat, katastrophale Chancenverwertung. Da hat ihnen vorne drin der Knipser gefehlt, Vlaović nochmal kurz, die Klammer wurde ja letzten Januar für sehr, sehr viel Geld an Juve abgegeben. Und das haben sie letztes Jahr an der Rückrunde noch auffangen können, aber bis Januar, Februar eben in dieser Saison nicht. Da haben Jović, der immer wieder verletzt war, nicht so geliefert, kommen wir auch gleich drauf. In den Pokalwettbewerben schon, in der Liga nicht. Cabral, den sie aus der Schweiz geholt haben, Brasilianer, hat auch nicht geknipst, aber gerade dieser Cabral hat jetzt angefangen zu knipsen und seitdem läuft es bei der Fiorentina, weil sie eben, wie gesagt, vom Ansatz her schon davor sehr, sehr gut unterwegs war, sehr mutig, sehr intensiv, 4-3-3, muss man den Kapitän Christiano Biragi nennen, Linksverteidiger, aber wenn du dir Fiorentina-Spiele anschaust, da sind die Außenverteidiger, gerade im Ballbesitz, haben die relativ wenig mit Außenverteidiger-Position zu tun, sondern ganz oft an der Grundlinie gehen, ganz vorne mit rein. Die Fiorentina bringt viele Spieler an den gegnerischen 16er, dementsprechend spielt sie sich eben vieles raus. Gutes Pressing, das war immer auch schon eine Stärke von Vincenzo Italiano. Also wirklich eine sehr, sehr gut anzusehende Mannschaft vor kurzem. Sie haben jetzt Milan und Inter in dieser Serie geschlagen vor kurzem. Das war dieses 1-0 in San Siro gegen Inter. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar daran, da lässt Lukaku eine Chance liegen, das glaubst du eigentlich nicht, dass irgendwie aus einem Meter leeres Tor und er setzten noch daneben. Aber das war so ein bisschen sinnbildlich, weil Fiorentina-Spieler wirklich, ja, da geht es hin und her, da ist viel Alarm drin, die Fiorentina macht viel fürs Spiel, ist mutig, also ist wirklich sehr ansehendlich. Und jetzt kommen wir eben zum Punkt, es geht ja nicht nur um diese Siege sehr in der Liga, sondern sie haben auch noch die Chance auf zwei Titel. Sie sind in der Conference League heute Abend gegen Lech Posen, das Hinspiel. Super im Rennen, haben da glaube ich die letzten Spiele alle gewonnen auch. Also haben auch ganz klar das Ziel, wir wollen da Richtung Finale. Und sie sind in der Coppa Italia, haben sie das Halbfinale-Hinspiel gegen Überraschungsmannschaft Cremonese auswärts 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Haben also wirklich sehr, sehr gute Karten da ins Finale einzuziehen. Da wird es dann gegen Into oder Juve gehen, also das wird ein richtig heißes Match auch werden. Also die Fiorentina ist eine Pokalmannschaft in dieser Saison, aber eben was die Leistung betrifft, auch in der Liga, jetzt belohnen sie sich für das, was sie eigentlich schon über die ganze Saison zeigen. Und interessante Transferstrategie, also du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Also wir kennen Luca Jovic, der ist jetzt gefallen. Arthur Cabral, der kam vom FC Basel damals. Und González vom VfB ist ja auch dorthin gewechselt. Absolut, das ist zum Beispiel – González war auch so ein Faktor, da war er in der Saison immer wieder verletzt, hat ja auch die WM verpasst. Der wäre eigentlich Teil des argentinischen Kaders gewesen, war jetzt ja auch wieder ein Perrufen bei der Argentinier. Der hat ihnen lange gefehlt, also der kommt jetzt auch wieder ins Rollen. Sofian Amrabat sagt wahrscheinlich einigen jetzt seit der WM was. Der so extrem wichtige Anker Marokkos vor der Abwehr quasi. Also da ist Qualität da und da ist aber auch ein Ansatz von Vincenzo Italiano eben, von diesem Trainer, der diese Qualitäten auch versucht, sehr dominant ins Spiel zu bringen. Also wie gesagt 4-3-3, mutig, die Außenverteidiger marschieren, auch ganz spannend finde ich er, ein Riesenverfechter davon. Seine zwei Außenstürmer ist immer, also auf links spielt ein Rechtsfuß und auf rechts ein Linksfuß. Er will, dass seine Außenangreifer torgefährlich ins Zentrum ziehen können, weil sie dadurch auch den Raum öffnen für die Außenverteidiger und die hinterlaufen fleißig, fleißig, fleißig und dann kommen die Achter auch da noch mit dazu vorne rein. Also wie gesagt, für ein Tina-Spiel kann man sich immer anschauen, weil da ist immer was los, das ist intensiv. Und deswegen auch Vincenzo Italiano, weil wir vorhin Thiago Motta hatten. Für mich auch ganz, ganz klar einer, der in den nächsten Jahren, was die italienischen Trainer betrifft, für mich wird der in einen sehr, sehr guten Weg gehen. Also ganz klar zu erkennen. Also wenn du ein für ein Tina-Spiel ansiehst, dann weißt du nach einer Viertelstunde oder 20 Minuten, was die wollen. Und das heißt aber nicht, dass die total dogmatisch sind, aber du siehst eine ganz klare Idee mit viel Intensität, viel Athletik, also auch ein europäischer, moderner Ansatz. Da bin ich mir sicher, dass Italiano seinen Weg gehen wird. Ich bin verwirrt, Christian. Ich bin ehrlich verwirrt. Ich dachte, es wird immer 1 zu 0 gespielt in Italien. Aber alles super defensiv und so weiter. Catenaccio ist ja auch nur ein Defensivsystem. Das kann man ausschließlich defensiv verstehen. Der Catenaccio hatte nichts mit Angreifen zu tun. Ach ist das schön. Ich mag die Ligatur. Diesen anderen Blick auf die Ligen. Aber wir sind jetzt am Ende dieser Ligatur angelangt. Es gibt nur noch die Matches to Watch natürlich, die ich abfragen muss. Jemand, der jetzt ganz lange nur passiver Zuhörer war, deswegen darf er jetzt als Erster sich melden. Jogi Hebel, was müssen wir in der Premier League unbedingt auf dem Schirm haben? Sowohl übertragungstechnisch als auch vom sportlichen her.
Ich würde sagen, Aston Villa gegen Newcastle wäre ein Spiel, das sehr interessant ist, weil Aston Villa jetzt so momentan unter Una Emery wieder richtig modern Fußball spielt und sich auf die Gegner einstellt. Und wie kaum ein zweites Team, die sind richtig am Kommen. Newcastle, wissen wir auch, die sind sehr, sehr unangenehm zu spielen. Sehr, sehr starke Defensive, die beste der Liga. Da bin ich echt gespannt, ob Aston Villa das so weitermachen kann. Die sind jetzt sechster, so richtig hochmarschiert. Das Spiel, würde ich sagen, dass so unterm Radar laufen wird, dass jetzt nicht jeder auf dem Schirm hat. Aber es ist 13.30 Uhr, es ist diese frühe Anstoßzeit, die der Engländer nicht so mag, die auf den asiatischen Markt abgestimmt ist. Aber ich glaube, das kann man sich schön anschauen. So mittagrum, schönes Fußballspiel, werde ich mir auf jeden Fall anschauen. Ich habe am Abend Manchester City, vielleicht ja auch fürs Rückspiel nochmal interessant, wie die sich gegen Leicester schlagen. Jetzt ja auch mit neuem Trainer, weil Dean Smith hier da übernommen hat, von Brandon Rogers. Und dann natürlich 15 Uhr am Sonntag Match of the Week mit den beiden Hebeln. Das kann ich nur empfehlen, auch um zu sehen, wie gut wir abonnieren.
Das werden wir sehen. West Ham gegen Arsenal, sollte man vielleicht nur dazu sagen, ist die Partie. Also am Rande wird es auch darum gehen.
Wir werden uns bemühen, da auch ein bisschen drüber zu sprechen.
Ja, sehr gut. Danke dir Jogi. Nils, was müssen wir in der Liga auf dem Schirm haben?
Ja, wenn ich eben schon den FC Valencia angesprochen habe, dann haben die auch jetzt wieder ein Abstiegsduell gegen den FC Sevilla im Mestalla. Das ist das, was sie in Hoffnung macht. Spannend auch, das baskische Derby der Athletik Club gegen Real Sociedad. Also in Bilbao, da steckt auch immer einiges an Geschichte und Nachwuchsarbeit dabei. Zwei ähnliche Vereine besonders. Und ich kann auch empfehlen, Real Madrid spielt in Cádiz. Ja, für Real Madrid geht es nicht immer um viel. Aber wenn man so in der Liga eine Auswärtsfahrt macht, dann am besten nach Cádiz, da freue ich mich schon drauf. Und das ist eben Samstag 21 Uhr, aber vielleicht am spannendsten Sonntagabend Valencia gegen Sevilla. Da geht es gegen den Abstieg.
Valencia gegen Sevilla. Was werden wir uns in der Ligue 1 zu Gemüte führen müssen, David?
Müssen? Lieber eben. Ach so, müssen im Sinne von must have, nicht?
Ja, natürlich, genau. Nein, das war jetzt nicht so, weil wir uns quälen. Meine Güte.
Sorry. Also jetzt Bezug nehmen wir auf das, was ich vorgestellt habe. Am Freitagabend kann man sich Toulouse gegen Lyon anschauen. Falls man bei Toulouse mal reinschauen will, dann kann man vielleicht auch mal achten auf Fares Shaibi, ein ganz spannender Spielmacher bei Toulouse, extrem variabel, der jetzt auch für die algerische Nationalelf berufen wurde. Samstag wäre die logische Antwort. Na ja, da spielt halt der Erste gegen den Zweiten, PSG gegen Lens, könnte ein Kracher-Spiel werden. Andererseits, wenn nicht, ja mein Gott, dann... Wenn Lens gewinnt, dann werden sie auf 3 Punkte ran. Da wäre es natürlich nochmal spannend, genau. Rennen gegen Rens ist ebenfalls am Samstag. Ich glaube aber, das wird nicht übertragen in Deutschland, wenn ich mich gerade richtig schnell informiert habe. Und natürlich ebenfalls Bezug nehmen auf das, was ich geschildert habe, die Woche drauf spielt Lens gegen Monaco. Und das wird tatsächlich für Monaco dann wiederum sehr, sehr wichtig, weil wenn die da wirklich nochmal oben heran kommen wollen auf ihre Champions League Plätze, auf denen sie sich ja eigentlich so ein bisschen sehen und wo sie zuletzt ja sehr, sehr unglücklich ausgeschieden sind in den letzten Jahren aus diversen Qualis, CL Qualis, dann wird das ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Spiel für Monaco, um da oben irgendwie nochmal einzugreifen.
Okay, ich sehe schon, wir werden viel Ligue 1 sehen und kaum noch Zeit haben, da irgendwas aus der Serie A mit reinzuquetschen. Wir wissen natürlich schon, Christian Bologna gegen Milan. Das ist am Samstag Nachmittag dieses Spiel. Gibt es noch was darüber hinaus? Ja, also Bologna-Milan, wie gesagt, eben sehr spannend, auch allein deshalb nicht nur wegen Thiago Motta und Bologna, sondern weil ja auch der Champions-League-Kampf sehr, sehr eng ist. Also Milan muss da schon auch schauen. Jetzt trotz, wir haben viel über Champions League jetzt und das besteht die Aussicht aus Halbfinale. Aber gerade beide Mailander-Clubs müssen in der Liga auch schauen, dass sie quasi die Champions-League-Quali über die Liga schaffen. Das ist sehr, sehr eng. Dementsprechend auch aus Milans Sicht sehr wichtig. Und wir haben am Montag dann Fiorentina gegen Atalanta zum Abschluss. Und wie gesagt, Atalanta auch immer noch in Reichweite, was Platz 4 betrifft, weil es eben so eng ist. Und die Fiorentina, die da auch versucht, eben jetzt noch mal da heranzuräumen. Wie gesagt, zwei haben wir, glaube ich, vorne mal angedeutet. Zwei der intensivsten Mannschaften auch in Italien. Also bei Fiorentina gegen Atalanta ist sicher einiges los. Und noch ein kleiner Blick auf die Woche drauf. Da ist dann Juve gegen Napoli. Das sollte man sich schon mal ankreiden. Da ist ja auch Napoli dann sozusagen die Champions-League-Nummer. Jetzt sage ich mal erst mal durch, das Viertelfinale. Vielleicht erinnere ich noch ein paar. Es gab im Januar dieses 5-1 von Napoli, das eigentlich so das Highlight-Spiel in der Liga auf dem Weg zu Jerms Colletto war, quasi wenn man auch die Rivalität zwischen Juve und Napoli kennt. Also da wird sicher einiges an Feuer drin sein. Das ist dann am Wochenende drauf. Ich mache mir mit dieser Ligatour komplett die Schlusskonferenzen zur Bundesliga kaputt. Aber ich kann da nichts dafür. Ich kann doch nichts dafür, Leute, wenn es überall sonst so spannend ist. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit und dass ihr hier wart. Herzlichen Dank an Nils Kern. Danke, lieber Jogi Hebel. Schön, dass du wieder hier warst, David Frogier de Ponlevoy.
Danke schön, hat Spaß gemacht.
Wie flüssig mir das einfach inzwischen von den Lippen geht.
Ich liebe es.
Und danke, lieber Christian, dass du hier warst. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 257. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Und indem wir uns weiterempfehlen an Freunden und Freunde, denen dieses Format und auch unsere anderen Formate gefallen könnte. Es gibt ja auch noch Tribüngespräche und die Schlusskonferenzen und so weiter und so fort. Es soll ein Medienimperium werden, der Rasenfunk. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Imperium. Macht's gut, ciao!